- [Narrator] Popcorn, movies, a match made
in theater heaven.
But there was a time when this was banned.
Popcorn has been around
for over 8,000 years,
but when it hit American
streets in the mid-1800s,
it took off.
It was cheap and could be
mass produced on the go,
not to mention it smelled amazing.
It was the go-to snack at circuses,
sporting events and fairs.
In fact the only place
you wouldn't find popcorn
was at the movies.
You see, going to the movies used to be
a major event.
The only people that went
were fancy rich folks
because you had to be
educated enough to read.
Fancy, like there was even a coat check.
But there was definitely
no concession stand.
There was, however, popcorn street vendors
who set up shop outside theaters.
They made a killing selling
to waiting theater goers.
Theater goers that started smuggling
their popped treats inside.
Not cool.
Early movie theaters kindly asked patrons
check their popcorn before entering.
Then, in 1927, films started adding sound,
meaning everyone went to the movies.
The Great Depression
followed making movies
a cheap escape.
Huge crowds plus crunch
muffling sound equaled
another revenue opportunity
for theater owners.
By 1945, over half the popcorn consumed
in America was being eaten at the movies.
A marriage that has continued ever since.
♫ To get ourselves a treat